As developers, both you
and I use HTTP everyday.
We issue GET and
POST requests when
using Firebase's JavaScript
SDK, or just when
using the browser on our
tablet's or mobile phones
to look at web sites.
To be a good front-end engineer
creating web apps, merely
using HTTP is not enough.
You will need a
deeper understanding
to see why certain
techniques are being used
and why others either don't
work, or aren't recommended.
In this lesson, we'll
start with a look
at the first version of HTTP.
We'll examine the GET
and the POST methods
and a few other useful
methods you might not
be as familiar with.
We'll look at a
variety of headers
and how APIs are designed
to work well with the web.
By the end of this
lesson, you'll
be able to debug HTTP request
response pairs on the wire,
and will understand
what a RESTful API is.